so here's Chris Pine you do the accent
you bet the costumes like to look right
you're in those grueling you know
conditions in Scotland filming for
months and then you premiere the film in
Toronto and that's not what got
attention oh dear what happened yeah
what happened well I have sorry there's
a scene in the film where I am I I bear
the and yeah that seemed well yeah full
monty the front or the back you know if
you don't like one you can talk together
it's all in here it's all different
strokes for different cases you know and
Potter and these are the tweets the
tweets mornings members Chris mind full
frontal outlaw King that's pretty much
where a review this is a PSA that are
looking for because max booty appetizer
of the frames featuring is soaking wet
full frontal nudity thankfully Netflix
has a pause
[Laughter]
better one that I think is vanity
mirrors like oh yeah there there five
there F and brutal yeah we've this one
there's one more near day one observed
it down until I've been seriously
impressed by the performances of
newcomers like crisp lines pubes and
crisp lines penis
[Music]
you